foreign
[Music]
everybody welcome to another edition of
BR Fantasy Live week 13 is here I'm your
host Ian hardits on behalf of PFF great
day to be great hope you guys had a
lovely Thanksgiving holiday and we have
a great show for you plenty of waiver
wire goodness to get set ahead of the
fantasy playoffs but first I want to go
through some of the big injury news as
always it's Wednesday or Thursday we
have all sorts of stuff going on in the
NFL that is never quiet out there so
with all that in mind Justin Fields is
back to practicing in full playing
through that left shoulder injury that
said everyone I would not immediately go
back to slotting him in as the top five
quarterback that we did see for a good
month stretch there playing through a
dislocated left shoulder is a very
painful injury it's something that we
saw not quite to this extent but Kyle
Murray trying to play through a couple
years ago and accordingly his coaching
staff wasn't as willing to put him out
there running the ball as much as he was
before the injuries so with Justin
Fields you take away his rushing ability
and all of a sudden things get that much
harder and fancy land so Justin Fields
still someone that look I would start
ahead of guys like the great Mike White
like Kirk Cousins you know Jared Goff
Jimmy Garoppolo all of that but it does
get closer when we start looking at the
Geno Smith and the Trevor Lawrence is of
the world we'll see what his end what
his injury designation ends up actually
being also Lamar Jackson is back to
practice on Thursday had that quad
injury pop up on Wednesday doesn't seem
like that's going to be too big of a
deal luckily ahead of this nice spot
here against a Broncos team that let's
face it doesn't seem to have all that
much to play for lately Leonard
fournette is back to practice in full on
Thursday with his hip injury so I know
how great last week was Rashad white
fantasy managers you've been waiting a
long time to go out there get that 91
snap rate and have that featured role
but what letter for net back I'm not
expecting white to be the same sort of
must start option that we had last week
this is not a full takeover here while
white has been a little bit better than
fournette on the ground both guys still
averaging under four yards per carry and
four Nets actually been the more
efficient receiver in terms of yard per
hour run so I do think white is going to
keep starting as does Buccaneers beat
reporter Greg almond but what Greg also
said is he thinks it's going to be a bit
of a hot hand approach comments that
were echoed by head coach Byron Leftwich
here last week so with fournette with
Rashad white rb3s neither needs to be
started until we have a little bit more
clear idea of what this backfield
breakdown is going to look like moving
forward
Travis etn had that foot injury last
Sunday pretty scary considering the guy
just missed an entire season with a foot
injury but he said after the game he is
straight and he has been able to
practice in a limited fashion
back-to-back time to start the week so
maybe we see Michael Hasty or Daryl
Henderson take a little bit more of the
workload than we had in past weeks but
still Travis CTN someone up I'm firing
up confidently as a top 15 option
finally guys Naji Harris is still not
practicing and that means that Jalen
Warren who did miss last week with a
hamstring injury could be out there
we'll see how big the roll is I know the
Steelers whether it's been Le'Veon
D'Angelo Williams even freaking Stefan
Ridley over the years week 17 18 James
Connor you can go on and on they've been
down to give their lead running back a
featured role I'm just not super
convinced Warren's gonna have that
coming off that hamstring injury himself
but again one of the more just fantasy
you know important situations to be
monitoring ahead of Sunday and with that
everybody let's get on to the main show
Welcome to BR Fantasy Live presented by
State Farm we have an awesome show on
tap for you guys today going through top
waiver wire additions you should make
now to help you end the fantasy football
playoffs now if you've been on this show
in the past I've had some handy dandy
charts that I continue to tweet out so
if you're not following me on Twitter at
iHeart it's ianheart it's you can go
find those for yourself but I use those
again I also just looked at some
handcuffed situations around the league
to get an idea of people you can add
right now where come week 15 come week
17 you're going to be a lot happier that
they are already on your bench as
opposed to having to go out there and
try to fight with everyone else on the
waiver wire so with that everyone let's
get into it starting things off with the
man of the hour man of the week New York
Jets starting quarterback Mike White now
we've only seen this guy for about four
extended appearances over the past two
years but it's been pretty good guys
third in yards per attempt in the league
and we saw last week 300 plus and three
touchdowns it is possible to get some
counting stats out of this talented
group of New York Jets pass catchers we
saw Joe Flacco do it during the first
three weeks of the year on fortunately
Zach Wilson just wasn't up to the task
but having healthy versions of Garrett
Wilson Elijah Moore Corey Davis stop
laughing if Corey Davis is your number
three wide receiver life could be a bit
worse out there I get the running backs
are banged up but we still have two
serviceable tight ends and Tyler Conklin
CJ izoma all this is suggesting that
Mike White doesn't need to be a hero out
there he just needs to be Mike white as
his head coach Robert Salas said he made
easy look easy last week that's all we
were asking for with this group of
weapons so
adding to the Allure of Mike White look
I just said before with Justin Fields if
he is going to be active of course I'd
be starting Fields over Mike White this
week might not be able to say that
though in a few weeks because nobody has
an easier playoff schedule from weeks 15
to 17 at the quarterback position then
Mike White he gets the Lions who are
dead last in fantasy points per game
allowed the quarterbacks in week 15
followed by the Jaguars who ranked 25th
and finally the Seahawks who rank 21st
so we have a quarterback who sure looks
like he's keeping the job the rest of
the season this is still a competitive
Jets team sitting there at seven and
four somehow looking like they have
maybe not a chance to make too much
noise in the playoffs but they're at
least trying to get there and I think
that we could see them get back to
passing the ball a little bit more when
Zach Wilson was under Center in weeks
four through eleven this was only the
22nd ranked offense in terms of pass
play rate and non-garbage time
situations but if you look at weeks one
through three with Flacco and then also
last week with Mike White number three
most pass heavy offense in the league so
I get it hopefully if you're in the
playoff you know you already have
Patrick Mahomes or Josh Allen that
helped get you there in the first place
if not though Mike White don't be
surprised if he is one of the Marquee
streaming options available come week
15. and by the way guys just so you
don't think I'm going out of my way to
recommend you know kind of out there
players to go pick up I made sure all
these guys were available and over 50
percent of leagues on ESPN and Yahoo so
as easy as will be to come up here and
you know recommend that oh Dak
Prescott's gonna be in a great position
at the end of the year I'm trying to get
you guys that you have a reasonable
chance to actually go out there and land
off the wave of wires so before again
the running backs want to go answer a
couple chat questions appreciate are you
that do tune in with us live here on BR
fantasy uh from at Ryan R ramandre
Stevenson Legacy game tonight he's 100 a
must start option we'll see about a
legacy game I think they are wearing
those cool throwback the red Patriots
unions where they got you know the
actual Patriot up there on the helmet
truly an underrated throwback jersey out
there but Stevenson Guys Without Damien
Harris I mean even with Dave even here
is playing a lot this season seventh in
expected PPR points per game which is
just a complicated way of saying one of
the most fantasy friendly workloads in
the entire league you cannot show me a
fantasy football lineup That should have
ramadri Stevenson anywhere other than
the starting rb1 spot from at Loop Tibbs
do I start Brian Robinson or Devin
Singletary
this is a tough one I have Singletary
ranked just a little bit higher but
Antonio Gibson has not been practicing
this week with a foot injury if he's not
going to be able to get out there I
would be ranking Robinson higher so
honestly Luke I think this is a tough
call I'm happy I'm not the one make it I
would lean towards going with Brian
Robinson at the end of the day the
Patriots are the number one defense in
fantasy points per game allowed to
opposing running backs Singletary has
still been having that commanding lead
even after they traded for nine Hines
but James Cook was starting to get a
little bit more involved over the past
two weeks ultimately Brian Robinson I do
think he has a chance if Gibson gets
ruled out to be the sort of top 15
option that you gotta start and it's not
that big of a drop off so I will chase
that ceiling look if you happen to be
like this massive 30-point favorite in
your game then maybe Singletary but give
me Robinson good question and from at my
Boston uh start Gabriel Davis tonight or
wait for Mike Williams I would
absolutely go with Gabriel Davis Mike
Williams has not been able to practice
on Wednesday or Thursday I have not
heard anything you know from reports
suggesting that he's particularly likely
to play this week give me Gabriel Davis
in that one
all right guys moving on to the running
back position so I'm still gonna be
talking about schedules for a lot of
these guys because that's important
especially in a three-week sample size
but it's also to the point where certain
running backs with certain workloads we
don't care about the matchup because of
all that volume they're getting and that
applies tenfold to Vikings running back
Alexander Madison someone that was well
over 50 on the start this season but we
get bored of handcuffs at a certain
point if the team starter doesn't get
injured which Stalin cook has not this
season say for a brief you know shoulder
flare up earlier on so Alexander Madison
still available and 65 percent of Yahoo
leagues and 77 of ESPN leagues any
someone that we've seen year after year
be a fantastic spot starter for dab and
cook when called upon specifically in
six games without Dalvin cook only one
dud in the other five games are before
seven six eight and 13 overall in full
PPR scoring so look the schedule doesn't
really matter when you happen to be a
running back and then Hoffman's willing
to give you 15 to 20 plus touches game
Alexander Madison is just one injury
away from getting that so yes this is a
new coaching staff with Kevin O'Connell
that we haven't seen have to deal with
the Dalvin cook injury the same way but
you look at that roster there's no one
like Amir Abdullah who used to be a bit
of a Thor in the side for someone like
Madison on passing downs and even in the
preseason the first team usage Madison
was getting Bell Cal uses so Alexander
Madison again before the season started
we everyone including myself had him
right there with the Tony pollards with
the AJ Dillons and Kareem hunt says the
guys who literally one injury away from
being an every week must start option
Madison still is that he's just
available in more leagues than you would
expect him to be
also the man of the week on the waiver
wire mostly because he wasn't owned on
any teams going into last week that's
gonna be Jets running back at Donovan
Knight again 37 owned on Yahoo only 20
on ESPN nice little debut for the guy
nickname bam which by the way just a
plus uh nickname to have for a running
back I don't know how you could ever get
that nickname and play another position
after that but Donovan number six best
schedule from weeks 15 to 17 facing the
Lions the Jaguars and the Seahawks
similar sentiment to what we just talked
about with Mike White where if the Jets
offense does stay competitive and just
improves her scoring upside a little bit
it seems like Solomon's going to be the
guy to take advantage of that
potentially in a major way now look the
guy went undrafted we've seen exactly 60
Minutes of professional football out of
the guy I've went back and looked at his
preseason stats and they weren't
anything overly impressive but guess
what he has a chance to get all that
sweet volume that helped Brees Hall and
to a lesser extent Michael Carter put up
some good fantasy value in their own
rights so Donovan Knight right now I
don't think he's someone that we can
feel incredible about but guys he
already passed James Robinson on the
death chart Michael Carter is not
practicing with the ankle injury who
knows when he's going to be back and
it's a situation where even if Carter
does come back it sure seems like
Donovan is already right there in a 1B
spot because he was already working
ahead of Ty Johnson last week as well so
this is one of those situations that
came out of nowhere I think in the past
you know if this happened in week two
maybe we'd be a little more skeptical
trying to wait things out a little bit
longer but again the playoffs are almost
here there's not much time to waste
don't be afraid to go get the guy who is
all of a sudden locked in seemingly for
15 plus touches a game and oh yeah it
just converted those into over 100 total
yards so this week you know with Mike
White again under Center joins Joe
Flacco as one of only two quarterbacks
with a check down rate over 10 percent
over the past two seasons zone of a
knight slowly but surely looking like
one of the potential Fantasy Playoff
studs from a pure volume perspective
I also want to talk about jarek McKinnon
here so he is dealing with a hamstring
injury he hasn't been able to practice
this week and we have seen McKenna a
little bit banged up throughout the year
so keep an eye on that but guys if not
he is the one running back in Kansas
City who we have seen have the potential
to get a legit three down roll don't
forget about that playoff runs by the
Chiefs last season where Jared McKinnon
was their feature back over a healthy
Clyde over Solaire and by healthy I mean
he was active and like dressing so maybe
he was banged up but what NFL player
isn't banged up by the time we get into
December and when McKinnon in those
playoff games 78 70 and 78 snaps with a
combined carries and targets totals of
18 17 and 16. so we've seen Isaiah
Pacheco yes he has the early down role
but do they like Ronald Jones I don't
think so they just played him for the
first time all season and didn't feel
good enough about it that they decided
to bring in Melvin Gordon and beyond
that look Ronald Jones might be the
single worst pass catching running back
in the league we've seen Melvin Gordon's
problems with even holding on to the
football Jared McKinnon is the most
reliable three down back on the Chiefs
and the only guy there where is
something were to happen to Pacheco I
think Andy Reid will be willing to give
him that full-time role and if he gets
that full-time roll down the stretch
look out because they get the Texans the
single worst defense against running
backs in terms of PPR points per game
allowed the position the Seahawks and
the Broncos who I'm guessing by week 17
aren't going to be feeling all that
great about you know Russ and where
their team is exactly standing at that
point so Jared McKinnon one of those
guys where again still available on over
60 and 70 percent of Yahoo and ESPN
leagues respectively someone that no not
a ton of Standalone value one injury
away from potentially being a weekly top
20 running back
appreciate you guys in the chat gonna
have a ton of start sick questions here
after I get to this position so make
sure you hang on for that from Goose
fournette or Singletary this week I
would be going with Devin Singletary
we're still not completely sure that
fournette is going to be out there he
did practice in full on Thursday so very
good sign but even then I mean
Buccaneers beat reporter Greg almond has
reported that he expects for shop white
to maintain the starting role and if
that's going to be the case all of a
sudden fournette's looking like a
committee back in an offense that has
not been able to run the ball all season
long so Singletary still playing over 70
percent of the snaps each and every week
even after they added Naim Heinz I will
take Devin in that question at Jake
Crowther thoughts on Isaiah Pacheco
again I was just you know talking about
McKenna more so as a handcuff it is
pacheco's backfield right now the
problem guys is they just don't really
throw him the ball only four receptions
all year and I'm not sure why to be
honest I mean if you guys watched the
Chiefs game last week the one catch he
did have they kind of designed them this
like you know screen or Cross or going
over the middle and hey I'm not going to
put 10 you know I played linebacker back
in the day for a reason I don't know too
much about how to catch a football
properly but just from my you know
untrained eyes sure look like Pacheco
has that skill set and he's been
returning kicks the whole year so I
don't view Pacheco as like just this
early down plotter you know it's not
exactly like a LeGarrette blunt type
there's a throwback name for you but
Pacheco at the end of the day he's got
that 15 to 20 carry roll which is very
similar to Jamal Williams but he's in
the number one ranked scoring offense in
the NFL so I think we can all agree that
you know if we were Jamal Williams
fantasy managers and we could decide hey
or just like his real life manager I
guess like would you rather have him in
the Lions or the Chiefs offense we would
probably actually pick the Chiefs
offense that's what we have in Pacheco
so every week rb2 the rest of the way
but that lack of a pass down rule is
going to stop him from ever getting too
high up the ranks that's life in full
PPR scoring historically guys you need
2.7 carries to reach the amount of
expected points that these running backs
get from just one single Target don't
hate the player hate the game
Kyron Williams now is another running
back I want to talk about here with the
Los Angeles Rams and I know this offense
has been absolutely abysmal
statistically the worst offense that
Sean McVay has ever coasted at the
professional level and that even goes
back to his days in Washington working
with uh Shanahan over there so with
Colin Williams here still I mean someone
that we've talked about I think on past
episodes here I know I've talked about
him a lot on the PFF fantasy football
podcast since he's only been playing
here three weeks after getting off IR
but guys the usage is slowly but surely
trending in a great Direction started
off his NFL career with four combined
carries and targets the next next week
he had nine last week he had 14 same
thing we're seeing here with the snaps
27 percent to 55 percent to 70 percent
of the snaps Daryl Henderson's out of
the picture cam Akers is not out of the
picture but my gosh like is it the
wildest thing to assume that the Rams
could decide to give King makers a seat
at some point Aaron Donald Matthew
Stafford Alan Robinson Cooper cup these
are all guys that are out and not
exactly look and all that great to come
back anytime soon I do believe there's a
scenario where Sean McVeigh ends up
saying eff it Kyron this is your
backfield because historically guys you
look at that girly role you look at the
CJ Anderson even cam makers Henderson
Sony Michelle rolls McVay has been one
of the few coaches not this year but in
the past to actually give his featured
rb1 that true 80 90 Workhorse role it's
basically him Cliff Kingsbury Kellen
Moore and Matt Canada with the Steelers
could honestly be more of a Tomlin thing
those are basically our four head
coaches that have been willing to give
that true you know 1990s style three
down never lead the field roll so that's
the best case scenario for Williams and
that's the sort of role we'll need to
make up for this brutal offensive
environment but guys the schedule fourth
best at the position with matchups
against the Packers Broncos and Chargers
down the stretch so Karim Williams hey
it's all about that sweet sweet volume I
don't think anybody expected Rashad
Penny to take over last season I mean
zone of it Knight is a guy that again
everyone is including myself
unironically touting sometimes you just
need to scrub out the player's name not
pay so much attention to all those you
know offensive red flags zero in more on
just that volume at the running back
position
also two more guys here where again not
much Standalone value for that's why I'm
projecting this for weeks 15 through 17
but I do think they are one injury away
from all of a sudden giving you a bunch
of production down the stretch DonTrell
Hillier Titans rb2 right now only owned
a 13 of Yahoo leagues and eight percent
of ESPN leagues seventh best schedule
down the stretch I mean they keep giving
Derrick Henry these late season games
against the Houston Texans if he's
active I'm sure he'll be going for 200
plus again because that's just what
Derrick Henry does but if not guys and
let's face it Derrick Henry continuing
to have this monstrous workload the most
carries in the NFL and we've seen him
get a little bit banged up already this
season albeit he hasn't missed any games
yet God forbid something happened to
Derrick Henry Don Joe Howard would be
the next man up and no I don't expect
Hillary to step in there and start
getting 20 25 carries as uh Derrick
Henry 2.0 I would expect Hassan Haskins
to be relatively involved as well but I
think the assumption that Haskins would
all of a sudden take on the Deontay form
role that foreman had behind Henry last
year might not be all that true because
Foreman is someone that as we've seen in
Carolina much more proven success at the
NFL level and I'm just not I don't think
it's a given that a fourth round rookie
is going to get that same sort of role
especially when you look at how they've
used the running backs this year I mean
if they really thought Haskins was a
better interior Runner than Don Joe
Hilliard why does Hilliard have 21
carries and Haskins only has 10 this
year and guess what even if Haskins does
take some of the early down work there
is no debate who's getting the pass down
work because Hilliard is already getting
that ahead of Derrick Henry himself so I
would expect this to be more of a pass
heavy offense without Derrick Henry
Megan doncho Hilliard I don't know a
lower middle class man's version of
Austin Eckler potentially down the
stretch against the Chargers Texans and
week 17 against the Cowboys so yeah week
17 maybe not the easiest match up there
but even then if there is one hole to
poke in that Cowboys defense probably
how they performed against the run this
season
and finally guys another just low-key
handcuff who happens to be attached to
one of the best and most highly ranked
running backs in all of fantasy football
Matt breida Giants rb2 and it's a very
similar sentiment as everything I just
said about Donald where no I don't think
that if saquan gets hurt they're just
gonna you know cross off his name put
Matt burrito there and run the offense
the exact same they do have Gary
Brightwell also employed and he's been a
little bit involved but not enough to
make me think that burrito would be
anything other than the lead back in a
potentially saquon Barkley less Giants
offense so on the season Matt burrito
has played 154 snap she's just 31 for
Gary Brightwell he's led the way and
Carries 34-10 I'm Excuse me nine to or
34-9 excuse me and then ten to two in
terms of targets so long way of saying
that map reader has been the easy
clear-cut number two running back I mean
look this is a situation where Brian
dabel felt good enough about him to
bring him back over from Buffalo after
coaching him with the bills in 2021 so
no I don't think Matt burrito is going
to be getting 20 carries a game just
like I don't think Donald Hillary will
be getting 20 carries per game should
the Titans and Giants lose their number
one but we'll take the pass down back in
these situations especially when they
can also give us 10 to 12 carries I
think both Donald and Matt breida have a
sneaky chance to do that and they're
just one injury away from having that
chance appreciate your chat at Brian lzq
should I add Josh Palmer AJ Dylan or
Kyron Williams so
if you're saying add that makes me
thinks that none of these guys are
exactly going to be starters because if
you need someone to start this week or
next week with six freaking teams on by
I would say Josh Palmer is probably
going to be your guy now when Mike
Williams gets back that'll complicate
things but we still see enough booms
from Palmer to give him the nod over
those guys if you're looking for Pure
upside though I would have to go with
Chiron because I don't think Kyron needs
an injury at this point to necessarily
get full control of the backfield AJ
Dylan would still need Aaron Jones to
get hurt but man that's a pretty nice
waiver wire you got over there man I'm
not gonna you know shame people for
being an eight eight or ten team leagues
but pretty good uh choices to have and
from at td86 Dolce or Hooper I'm gonna
lean out great dolches just by a little
bit here but I'll tell you what guys I
do have a tight end to talk about a
little bit later in Tyler Conklin that
might actually be better than both those
guys if he is available in your league
but before we get on to my guy Tyler
Conklin let's talk some of these wide
receivers now I said before that all
these guys are owned and over 50 percent
of League I'm cheating just a little bit
here with Brown's wide receiver Donovan
people's Jones only available in 48 of
Yahoo league so sorry guys you know but
still over 45 I'm sorry 55 of ESPN
leagues you can still go out and get dpj
who just so happens to be DeShaun
Watson's new 2022 edition of will Fuller
so yes Amari Cooper still clearly the
number one pass game option in Cleveland
but hey dpj easily could be the number
two during any given week I mean last
week first time since week three he's
been held under 50 receiving yards and
unfortunately with Dave and the Joker
dealing with his knee injury I mean they
might not have a choice but to feature
people's Jones more down the stretch so
you look at the schedule for Browns wide
receivers in the fantasy playoffs fifth
softest of any team out there they get
the Ravens the Saints and the commanders
in weeks 15 to 17 and again it's a bet
on dpj continuing to be solid which he
has all year and taking that to another
level with the Sean Watson under Center
and hey I was very surprised with how
well Jacoby said that played this year
just being an average Quarterback is all
you can ask from a backup but make no
mistake about it I'm not asking you to
like the guy or approve what he did or
anything like that but the Sean Watson
during his time with the Texans was
anybody's idea of a top five fantasy
quarterback and not a minimum a top 10
real life quarterback so anytime you can
get someone that is going to be the
number two pass game option for that guy
don't be afraid to go get dpj and
honestly fire him up as a wide receiver
three in fantasy land as early as this
week also keep an eye on potential
Ravens wide receiver one as sad as this
is can we get Lamar Jackson uh extra
weapon other than Mark Andrews at some
point please I know her shop babe and
got hurt but hey guys the Marcus
Robinson available in over 85 percent of
leagues on Yahoo and ESPN coming off a
week two weeks ago where he had nine
catches for 128 yards last week he
dudded but it really wasn't if you watch
the game should have had a 50-yard
touchdown catch on the second play of
the game unfortunately Lamar sailed it
and yeah Demarcus got back at Lamar by
dropping a 12-yard touchdown later in
this game so please don't mistake this
out for Lamar slander they dropped three
freaking touchdown passes last week so I
want Lamar to get more help but guess
what DeSean Jackson is pretty much the
only guy they brought in and as great as
djax's 60-yard catch and rum was at the
end of last week more like catch and
fall down 60 yards downfield but you
guys get it the Marcus Robinson profile
is as their most pure wide receiver one
at this point Devin Duvernay continues
to be someone that I think they view
more in a gadgety form and either way
it's Duvernay and Demarcus at the top of
that depth chart looking ahead two weeks
15 to 17 nobody has an easier schedule
at the wide receiver position they get
the Browns the Falcons and the League
worst Pittsburgh Steelers secondary in
those three weeks so hey Lamar Jackson
accounted for 12 total touchdowns in
weeks one through three somehow he only
has eight in weeks four through twelve
God forbid we started seeing Lamar
Jackson get hot as a passer down the
stretch Demarcus Robinson by default
it's going to be a big reason why so
just look across to wave a wire yourself
how many legit starting top two wide
receivers are out there Demarcus
Robinson is one of them as is Houston
Texans wide receiver Nico Collins still
available in over 75 percent of leagues
on Yahoo and ESPN alike and with Nico
it's one of those things where I
actually think he has a better chance of
Demarcus Robinson of maybe seeing more
consistent volume because let's face it
things haven't exactly been great with
Brandon Cooks in the Texans this year
from the trade deadline tobacco to them
you know seemingly making up that chest
injury afterwards and easing him back
into action and you look up and you know
Brandon Cooks he's had a fantastic
career he's overcome a lot of bad
quarterbacks in recent years after
having the opposite of that starting out
his career all those you know Brady
Breeze and all those years he had Watson
before that but Nico Collins has been
objectively better than Brandon Cooks
this season you can look at passer
rating when targeted Yaris run yards per
reception PFF receiving grade pick your
metric and Nico has been better than
Brandon Cooks and the Texans seem to be
recognizing that I mean last week Nico
ran a route on 80 of Kyle Allen's
dropbacks Brandon Cook's down there just
at 70 percent and they've been targeted
on the same percentage of their routes
run this season so you can actually look
at some of the numbers and make a case
that Nico is already the Texans number
one receiver and I know it's the Texans
but again if we take Cooks out of the
picture somehow just because it's a
one-91 team with nothing to play for and
Cooks is like the one player they've
decided to give any sort of financial
assets to over the years all of a sudden
Nico Collins could be getting those
eight plus targets per game that would
make anybody a viable wide receiver
three in Fantasyland especially with the
schedule down the stretch Chiefs Titans
and jaguars ranked 26-29 and 18th and
fantasy points per game allowed to be
opposing wide receivers don't be afraid
to get legit starting top two if not top
one wide receivers on the waiver wire in
Demarcus Robinson and Nico Collins
in the chat at Miller Lite KB Gibson or
Kyron Williams probably Carmen Williams
man Antonio Gibson looks like he could
be missing this game with a foot injury
and if he's going to go into the
match-up questionable that's going to be
problematic but if he is you know full
on Friday and he's not even listed with
an injury designation I do think we can
go back to the well with Gibson as
impressive as Brian Robinson was last
week the week before that Gibson out
carried him and even helped get him
those first downs down the stretch to
help Isis so still think it's a two-man
backfield in Washington as great as
Robinson's performance and big hat
display was last week from at gray89
Christian Watson or Tyler Lockett that
is a very good question ma'am looking up
my handy dandy ranks which you can find
at pff.com I do have Christian Watson
just a little bit ahead of Tyler Lockett
this week I mean the only concern for
Watson is overall Target volume he
hasn't had more than eight targets over
these past three weeks but my god the
guy scores six touchdowns over a
three-game period tough to keep him keep
him out of the lineup especially knowing
that that Aaron Rodgers going to be out
there and knowing this Browns defense
hasn't been able to slow anybody down
for the better part of the past six
weeks which hey that's what happens when
you know you sell all your good
defensive assets at the trade deadline
at tight end in a couple defenses for
you guys before we get to our start and
sit section but Tyler Conklin kind of
spoiled it before Jets tied M1 we've
said a lot of jets here because of how
sweet their schedule is in weeks 15 to
17 and with an actual passable NFL
quarterback under Center and Mike White
we can start getting excited about these
guys again so what Tyler Conklin only
owned in 21 of Yahoo leagues 33 percent
of ESPN leagues the single best schedule
down the stretch at the tight end
position they get the lions in week 15.
then the Jaguars then the Seahawks
nobody has it better and guys just in
four games already without Zach Wilson
under Center we've seen some consistent
fantasy goodness out of the man who's
already the overall tight end 11 on the
season I mean think about that Tyler
Conklin has had to spend half the season
with Zach Wilson not doing anything
under Center and the guy still is an
overall 10 M1 so far so in those four
games without Zach Wilson we've seen
Tyler Conklin go for 16 yards in a
touchdown six catches for 40 yards eight
catches 484 yards and three catches for
50 yards so hey even in one game with
Zach Wilson he managed to pop off for 79
yards and a pair of touchdowns this is a
guy with two top three finishes already
to his name don't be surprised if Tyler
Conklin if you need a tight end streamer
ends up being the guy that everyone
wishes they had come fancy playoff time
and with that everyone let's jump into
personalized fantasy advice presented by
State Farm with a personalized price
plan it's all about creating a price
just for you chat start sick questions
are here I got some time good 10 minutes
give me what you got at lennis powder Jr
should I start Warren over Pierce
no I am not sure what P what Warren's
role is exactly going to be this week I
mean he didn't practice at all last week
with that hamstring injury he said you
know on Tuesday or Wednesday that he got
cleared but I just have a hard time
believing that they're going to give him
a sort of Workhorse role that we would
need to have to make do in a Steelers
offense that has just been so Dreadful
this season so I know it's been gross
with Damian Pierce but it's been more so
that Texans offense and when you're
facing the Browns defense that is 31st
in scoring and just any stat you want to
look at it have been brutal this year
give me Damien Pierce big time bounce
back potential this week from at the far
Gus latavius or Jeff Wilson Jr at the
flex I'm gonna lean just a little bit
towards Jeff Wilson Jr I think latavius
is fair but we do need to keep an eye on
Mike Boone to see if he's going to be
back in Action this week so ultimately
it is a tough matchup against the 49ers
but this Dolphins offense so high
scoring when they really get rolling I
want their rb1 over these guys who again
might have a little bit more volume but
who are we going to take the scoring
upside from Miami Denver or Baltimore
give me the guy in Miami
from at kpat 12 one under the radar star
that could win your league good question
my friend I'm gonna go ahead and talk
about just a collection of guys it's
going to go back to our previous
discussion but the New York Jets have
been a team that has been willing to
throw the ball enough to really produce
some fantasy Stars down the stretch and
I think they have the potential with the
schedule and with the way their volume
is starting to break up to produce
multiple fantasy assets that you can get
behind each and every week at each and
every position so Mike White at
quarterback again this offense without
Zach Wilson under Center third most pass
happy group in the league and I've taken
out the garbage time numbers in that so
that's not just an impact of you know
looking at the specific game script and
everything Mike Weiss can be throwing
the ball a lot because that's what
they've done and why wouldn't they their
top two running backs are now out of the
picture as well so that leaves Donovan
Knight to hopefully take over a
backfield that why wouldn't he take over
if there aren't many other mouths that
can actually go in there and start
eating up those Touches at wide receiver
Garrett Wilson finally seems to be
getting featured now tight end Tyler
Conklin again already a top 12 player at
the position this year and now we have
even better reason to believe that he's
gonna be seeing more fantasy friendly
targets down the stretch with again that
number one schedule out to position in
weeks 15 to 17. so the New York Jets I
know their record has been surprising
this year in sauce Gardner and that
defense have been the primary reason why
they've been so good but we have seen
flashes without Zach Wilson of all these
talented pieces on offense making some
fantasy production go their way I do
think that could continue to happen here
down the stretch when it matters most in
the fantasy playoffs
from at me MD uh rashab White Zeke or
Swift in the flex so if Leonard
fournette ends up playing which it does
look like he's going to I will take
Ezekiel Elliott here I mean this is a
Cowboys offense that we have seen really
start to catch their stride with Dak
Prescott under Center and this Colts
defense ever since they lost Shaquille
Leonard formerly Darius Leonard at
linebacker just hasn't been the same
monster against the run so we've already
seen them get flamed plenty of times and
while Tony Pollard is out producing Zeke
more weeks than not I thought last week
was easily the best zika's look since
that injury in arguably all season long
so with Zeke it's one of those things
where think of him you know remove all
your you know concerns about Zeke's 90
million dollar contract and all that
think of him like a Jamal Williams or an
Isaiah Pacheco he's getting 15 to 20
carries inside of a really good scoring
offense so you should probably start him
over guys like Rashad white and DeAndre
Swift who don't have quite that same you
know goal line scoring opportunity at
least for right now we don't know for
sure about that with white in regards to
fournette if fournette is going to be
out though definitely Rashad White
from at Lindsay heinzy Jamal Williams
Donovan Knight ayok Hasty or Sutton need
three so I believe etn is going to play
so that takes out Michael Hasty out of
it among the other guys I would probably
Lane Jamal Williams Donovan Knight and
Brandon ayok Debo Samuel didn't practice
on Thursday which is interesting I think
Sutton versus ayok is a is a fair
conversation to have but at the end of
the day it is a 49ers offense over a
Broncos offense that hasn't been able to
do anything man I mean the fact that
Cortland Sutton doesn't have KJ Handler
doesn't have Jerry Judy in there and the
guy still can't you know get more than
this top wide receiver three sort of
treatment It's just sad to see what has
gone down in Denver but yeah I mean you
guys have seen it Russell Wilson has 12
bathrooms in his Denver house Nissan
pays to throw for 13 passing touchdowns
this year more bathrooms and passing
touchdowns I'm gonna stay away from most
wide receivers involved in that sort of
offense
from at Big Boy Joey T Higgins or Keenan
Allen I am going to be going with t
Higgins just by a little bit I know
Jamar Chase is back but McKeen and Allen
we've seen them be willing to spread the
ball out this season ever since he's
been back Austin Eckler actually leads
this offense with 17 targets over the
past two weeks and Keenan's right there
at number two the problem is DeAndre
Carter as well as Josh Palmer right
there behind Keenan with uh between 12
to 15 themselves so Keenan Allen is
looking a little bit better uh but in
that one I will be taking uh the other
guy so at richbone Dawson Knox or fossa
Moreau this week
it's a good question I'm gonna lean I'm
gonna lean Dawson Knox I just like the
scoring upside a little bit more in
Buffalo I know it hasn't been there as
much this year as it was last year but
with Foster Moreau at the end of the day
he's always going to be the number three
option behind Devonte Adams behind Josh
Jacobs in that Raiders offense and if
we're talking about complimentary
options give me the complimentary guy in
Buffalo as opposed to the one in Vegas
uh from at Dallas Metcalf Zeke or David
Montgomery this is where I will be
taking David Montgomery this dude gets
so much Flack and I don't blame people
for not having watched a ton of Bears
games uh this year even over the past
couple years but like breaking tackles
isn't a bad thing and yeah I get it
Montgomery doesn't exactly have that
sort of long speed to you know take a
five-yard gain turn into an 80-yard
touchdown but you know those types of
plays aren't exactly happening all that
much for other running backs either so
Montgomery without Khalil Herbert in the
picture it has become much more of a
cemented three down Bell cow ultimately
I see him having a much better chance of
getting those 20 plus opportunities and
the pass down stuff will separate for me
guys Zeke in the past used to be
averaging you know 25 30 plus receiving
yards per game career low four receiving
yards per game for Zeke this year give
me David Montgomery
from at Bensky Terry McLaurin or Keenan
Allen oh I have these guys like right
next to each other how sad is it that
with Terry McLaurin like we get Taylor
heinecke under Center and it's like a
breath of fresh air I mean can we get
this guy in a league quarterback at one
point in his career I am going to go
just towards Terry McLaren though as sad
as it is with heinecke I do trust his
overall volume a little bit more in an
offense that started to ignore Curtis
Samuel and this could be a pretty
smashable match up here so Terry against
Any Corner has been great I mean we've
seen him ball out against giant
Alexander and Stefan Gilmore and the
biggest moments of the game in their
direct coverage and the Giants will be
trying to do that to him with the Dory
Jackson but he's gonna be missing at
least another week or two with that knee
injury
from at Caleb go uh trailon Burks or
George Pickens give me George Pickens
treyland Brooks did pop up on the injury
report with an illness but even if he's
good to go Pickens one of the best
matchups of the week against that bottom
three Falcons defense and PPR points per
game allowed the positions maybe just
maybe Kenny Pickett can start getting
his stuff together enable these wide
receivers to some goodness and fantasy
from atlébo standard League Hunter Henry
or Cole commit I'm still gonna lean ah
man that's tough
if Fields can come back I don't think
he's going to be able to run as much
which would mean more passing so I would
take commit with Fields under Center
otherwise give me Hunter Henry how is
that not a touchdown catch for Hunter
Henry last week I still have no idea
guys but I guess you got to make that
decision tonight
um because you gotta make decision
tonight give me Hunter Henry I think
it's close enough that let's just take
the guy that we're more confident in has
a somewhat passable offense going for
them at Preston underscore Lewis do I
start Justin fields or Lamar this is
where I would still go with Lamar
Jackson again guys Justin Fields is
playing with this dislocated left
shoulder and I cannot speak to having a
dislocated shoulder but I'll tell you
what just back in my day just uh you
know mediocre linebacker in high school
in Ohio worst injury I ever suffered was
that shoulder and just running backs
with ribs and shoulder issues not trying
to say that Fields is a running back I
know he's capable of throwing the ball
but I would not be surprised at all if
this team really takes their foot off
the gas in terms of what Fields can do
as a design rusher and this is a guy
that literally I believe was fifth in
the NFL in rushing yards before that
injury occurred so you take away you
know Fields ability to run the ball it's
like taking Christian McCaffrey and
saying you can't catch passes out there
and expecting him to have great fantasy
production give me Lamar Jackson out of
pure health reasons
from at Ryan underscore beverage Zeke or
Jeff Wilson I have them very close to
each other if Raheem moster remains
sidelined I would go with Jeff Wilson if
he moster comes back I will give it to
Zeke just by a hair from at tck podcast
Pollard or waddle and the flax gobby
jail model dude is fifth in the NFL and
receiving yards and as great as Pollard
has been look Jalen waddo is a cemented
top 10 wide receiver at this point Paul
ironic more of an upside rb2 as long as
Zeke's gonna also be getting 15 20
touches per week from at Allen at Naji
Singletary or Jeff Wilson I don't think
Naji is going to play making it between
Singletary or Jeff Wilson I would go
ahead and just give it to Devin
Singletary I think it's very close
between those guys I would probably drop
Jeff Wilson below Singletary if we knew
moster was playing it does seem to seem
like he has a decent shot at doing so
from at Stan Hayes Jamal Williams or
Alvin Kamara still got to go with Alvin
Kamara I know it's been a rough few
weeks he lost two fumbles last week but
the receiving workload's still there
third most fantasy points per game in
terms of pure receiving production for
Alvin Kamara this season facing that
Buccaneers defense that we know always
does a good job against the Run
hopefully that compels Andy Dahl in the
company to throw the ball more than ever
from at Doza Pickens Garrett Wilson or
Burks at wide receiver too just loading
up on those talented rookie receivers
love to see it I am going to give the
edge to Garrett Wilson here going up
against a Vikings secondary that I think
has been started to get exploited a
little bit here in recent weeks and hey
look just beyond even bashing the
Vikings Garrett Wilson in his own right
oozing Talent all season long they just
couldn't really get on the ball that
much with Zach Wilson under Center and
hey even he had a couple good games with
Zach Wilson so I was a little bit
worried about Corey Davis coming back
last week but at the end of the day
Garrett Wilson had eight targets and I
don't believe a single other jet had
more than three so if they are going to
feature Garrett Wilson as that clear-cut
number one wide receiver which why
wouldn't you drafting them you know as a
top 10 pick for a reason we're going to
go ahead and give the nod to Garrett
Wilson in this one
from at biscuit Pierce or Montgomery I
will be taking David Montgomery just
barely we have seen the Texans get down
these games then they start featuring uh
you know guys like Dario gumbawale and
Rex Burkhead out there not throwing a
ball with Damian Pierce as much as we
prefer so Dave Montgomery I know the
offense isn't always the prettiest out
there but we've seen this Green Bay
Packers team I mean look what the Eagles
did to them last week run the football
not saying Montgomery is going to be
that good but I do like his volume a
little bit more and again I just think
the overall Nationwide sentiment that
Montgomery is this quote-unquote bad
football player could not disagree with
that more
from at M McDonald Keenan Allen Michael
Pittman or cpat at the flex man I just
always have to answer no to these
questions about corduro Patterson which
pains me as long time you know president
of his fan club I'm gonna have to go
with Keenan Allen just by a hair over
Michael Pittman that Cowboys defense no
joke number two ranked scoring unit I I
believe and just with this Colts
offensive line I mean that's been
low-key the biggest problem of this
group this season we can blame it on the
coaches Matt Ryan Jonathan Taylor that
offensive line would be who I would pick
taking most of that blame facing Michael
Parsons in that League best defense and
pressure rate I'll be taking Keenan
Allen in a much more likely shoot out
there between the Chargers and Raiders
three more everyone appreciate you
sticking with us this whole way at Keith
Abdullah people's Jones or at Nico
Collins I will be taking people's Jones
to former Michigan guys you know out
there you know I think Nico won third
people's Jones went a little bit later
in the draft but both guys have really
good profiles and I am you know
optimistic both guys can have nice
little season and stretches but come on
we got number two two wide receiver for
Kyle Allen a number two wide receiver
for DeSean Watson I will take the guy
for the Browns
at wlvz Star Jacoby or Dalton Schultz at
the flex always interesting when you get
the tight ends going here because of how
banged up Jacoby Myers is right now I
know shefter said he is going to be
playing really tough matchup I'm go
ahead and go with Dalton Schultz here
with Dak Prescott under Center guys he
has only missed in one game so far so
the Colts have been one of the League's
better defenses against wide receivers
so could see Schultz actually find a
little bit more volume than usual from
that standpoint and also just you know
the Cowboys offense again really
starting to catch their stride second
highest implied team total of the week
give me Schultz and finally at love and
football Aaron Jones or Jamal Williams
gotta go with my guy a Aeron here eight
touchdowns in his last six games against
the Bears I know Aaron Rodgers has said
and been very vocal about him owning the
Bears over the years Aaron Jones if he
wanted to you know go make that same
point I think he would be just fine so
guys that's gonna wrap up another
edition of BR Fantasy Live presented by
State Farm can't thank you guys enough
for tuning in and throughout the season
been a fun time and here we are week 13.
go win those matchups only two more of
them before we get in those fantasy
playoffs and come back around next
Thursday 5 p.m Eastern we'll be back
with more advice more goodness trying to
get that Championship goal so thanks
again for tuning in I'm Ian Hardison
until next time take care everybody